[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis prof et je n'aime pas l'école
c'est dommage mais je n'ai jamais aimé
l'école mais c'est pas grave car dans la
vie il ya d'autres manières de réaliser
ses ambitions d'autres manières
d'accéder à ces objectifs il ya un mois
j'ai fait la rencontre d'une
personnalité connue en france pour son
leadership sa combativité et bien sûr sa
volonté d' à chaque fois vouloir
progresser cette personne je suis fan
d'elle elle a été un passeport il est
elle a était petite devinette
elle a été capitaine de l'équipe de
france de handball double championne du
monde
médaille de bronze aux jeux olympiques
de barcelone pour te drapeau de l'équipe
de france aux jeux olympiques d'athènes
il s'agit bien sûr vous l'avez deviné je
n'ai entendu
jackson richardson ce type là je le
regardais dans mon canapé quand j'étais
gosse il me faisait vibrer avec son
style caractéristique bien sûr ses
dreads et il portait un message fort
parce que c'est le capitaine il avait
cette volonté toujours en et son équipe
ou plus haut maintenant aujourd'hui
jackson et entraîneur et il ya un mois
j'ai eu l'occasion d'assister à un de
ses matches et figurez vous que j'ai
même eu la chance de prendre celle ci
on a eu une discussion qui était magique
à la fin d'un de ces matchs non en vrai
il y avait de la neige derrière je me
les cahiers grave et durant cette
conversation qui était magique pour moi
puisque je l'observé depuis longtemps et
puis j'avais enfin l'occasion de lui
poser des questions
je vais poser la question suivante
jackson selon vous quel est le secret
qui peut nous mener vers le sommet nos
ambitions elham a dit francis je
t'arrête tout de suite il n'y a pas de
secret pour atteindre le sommet de ses
ambitions il faut avoir envie être bien
conseillé et ne jamais s'arrêter de
progresser premièrement avoir envie
personne dans la vie avant jackson ne
m'avait dit que à chaque fois que
j'avais une forte ambition je devais
agir avec une seule et unique chose mon
coeur bat le coeur de papa maman mon
coeur et ça j'ai compris bien et c'est
tard on a tous eu l'exemple tous dans la
salle vous allez vous reconnaitre on a
tous eu l'exemple de ce petit enfant se
dirigeant vers vous le sourire aux
lèvres avec les yeux pétillants en vous
disant qu'il voulait devenir plus tard
astronautes superstar président des
états unis et nous dans un réflexe
d'adultes blasé de la vie on ne pouvait
s'empêcher d'esquisser un petit sourire
avant de lui expliquer que ce serait
sans doute très difficile que ce ne
serait pas forcément pour toi
souvenez vous la petite on va l'appeler
clémentine la petite clémentine qui
disait moi moi quand je serai grande je
veux devenir chanteuse
comme madonna et en plus je veux faire
le tour de la terre et vous là en face
vous étiez là en train de dire bon
écoute clémentine on se calme
tu finis tes haricots verts ensuite il
va au lit parce que demain à l'école ici
on a typiquement l'exemple d'une
ambition qui n'est du coeur très tôt
mais qui est stoppé par un adulte de
confiance et qui aurait pu faire naître
un grand potentiel et ça quand c'est
stopper c'est mal et pour ça il est donc
très important dans toutes vos ambitions
d'être bien conseillé
vous devez vous trouvez un environnement
qui vous conditionne à réussir kivu
conditionne à être limitless sans limite
vous devez trouver et chercher c'est pas
forcément facile
trouvez votre mentor qui sera vous
connaître qui sera vous sentir et qui
vous donnera les meilleurs aspirations
pour vous c'est pas facile mais ça se
trouve et je pense que ce conditionnée à
être ambitieux peut commencer dès le
berceau
moi ça m'a toujours fait rire vous savez
les jeunes parents complètement gaga
parce qu'ils ont leur premier enfant
et quand ils se quand il se présente en
face du berceau dans lequel il ya leurs
enfants eh bien il était là agouazi oui
et biscuits trop mignonne trop gnangnan
le web et revenir à niort et l'autre à
niort il betty fille leurs enfants alors
qu'en fait je vous rassure on peut
parler normalement à nos enfants en
faisant des phrases simples
certes mais des phrases et on gagnera
énormément de temps sur les
apprentissages donc avoir un langage
normal dès la naissance est une marque
d'ambition alors des enfants j'en ai à
titre personnel j'en ai 347 sais pas ce
que vous croyez vous explique
en fait comme je le dis je suis prof du
coup j'ai des classes des élèves et il
n'y a pas très longtemps
j'étais en charge une classe de
terminale pas très loin d'ici dans le
fun de la haute vienne
c'est pourquoi je pense cette fois-là
abdelak village champêtre mais hautement
merveilleux et dans cette classe gt 24
super mignon supercar tout va bien et
vous savez le premier jour on se
présente on fait les présentations
à ce moment là j'ai décidé de mener une
petite expérience dans un premier temps
je me suis présenté oralement pendant
dix minutes et ensuite je les ai laissés
se présenter sur un petit bout de papier
pour kilomètres pour qu'il mette
m'inscrive dessus leurs aspirations
personnelles
alors j'ai commencé par présenter
bonjour je m'appelle francis voilà ils
m'ont demandé si francis était mon vrai
prénom
ça commence bien et ensuite je leur ai
dit que j'étais j'avais une passion dans
la vie une passion le voyage je leur ai
raconté donc que j'avais fait plus de 15
pays que chaque voyage était une étape
supplémentaire dans mon développement
personnel et suite à cette présentation
ils ont donc eu une libre expression sur
sur leur fiche
et quand je suis rentré chez moi et que
j'ai lu les fiches qu'ils avaient rédigé
les trois quarts de la classe avait
mentionné dessus le voeu de voyager
faire le tour du monde et rencontrer
d'autres cultures
ici on a vraiment un exemple concret ou
un adulte référent de confiance par une
action anodine parfois conditionne les
cerveaux et conditionne la pensée des
jeunes
et voilà une manière de pouvoir entre
autres changer le monde j'ai fait
exactement la même expérience beaucoup
plus récemment avec une classe pareil de
terminale es dont 16 17 ans cette fois
ci sur caen en normandie classe de 35 à
un peu plus chargé un peu plus fourni et
là par contre j'ai inversé le processus
je ne me suis pas présenté jeu
les laisser se présenter pour ensuite
dévoiler ma personnalité
hélas le résultat a été sans appel aucun
mât est fait référence au voyage
on avait majoritairement eu des
aspirations classique
on a même eu beaucoup de choses
farfelues du genre posséder une ville à
devenir riche
sortir avec beyoncé des choses beaucoup
plus fantaisistes mais je n'y croyais
pas voilà c'est de la dérision
alors que c'est une bonne ambitions
finalement dans la lignée de cet âge
adolescents vous savez versée et en
avait 15 15 ans on nous demande une
chose dans le système scolaire c'est de
faire un choix quant à notre orientation
et en france ont des champions pour ça
puisque des études de l'éducation
nationale menée sur du post bac pointe
un taux alarmant d'échec dans l'année
suivant l'obtention du baccalauréat ont
choisi on change on se trompe on arrête
on reprend à la haye ce que les lacunes
accumulées durant l'expérience scolaire
est la seule explication à ce désastre
lié à l'orientation
je ne pense pas je pense que le manque
d'ambition chez nos jeunes a sa part de
responsabilité dans cet échec
je pense que nous demandent trop tard
d'être ambitieux ce n'est que vers l'âge
de 15 ans qu'on vous demande de faire un
choix de vie énorme ainsi l'ambition
peut commencer très tôt plutôt vous
commencerez à être ambitieux plus tôt
vous connaîtrez vos aspirations
personnelles et plutôt vous saurez faire
des choix de vie qui vous permettront
d'être épanoui au quotidien ça semble
anodin mais c'est énorme comme le disait
le chanteur orelsan dans son dernier
album
à cet âge-là l'adolescence tourné au
moment de ta vie
ou tu peux devenir ce que tu veux le
même moment où c'est le plus dur de
savoir ce que tu veux et ça je peux vous
dire que yann grande partie des jeunes
présents dans la salle qui savent de
quoi je parle on devient ambitieux trop
tard astro personnel voilà compte
rapidement on est entre nous il n'y a
pas grand monde aujourd'hui
j'ai passé un bac s on m'a dit le bac
scientifique c'est le meilleur tu avoues
artois le choix tu va choisir mais
choisir quoi c'est pas d'ambition je
sais même pas quoi choisir donc
finalement l'ambition doit être la
source de nos motivations
enfin le dernier point c'est qu'il ne
faut jamais s'arrêter de progresser ne
jamais se reposer sur ses lauriers et
pour ça une méthode assez simple qu'on
peut faire tous les jours c'est être
inspiré quand vous êtes inspiré vous
avez envie quand vous êtes inspiré vous
avez envie de créer voir les choses en
grand et ça vous fait rêver ça vous fait
du bien et tout commence ici alors on a
chacun nos trucs pour être inspiré ici
on va pas s'appesantir dessus mais on se
rend compte dans la plupart des cas que
l'inspiration vient d'autant plus
rapidement lorsqu'on est libre libre de
penser sans s'attacher à de quelconques
considérations sociales à titre
d'exemple le un titre que vous pourrez
faire ce week-end pensera à moi face à
francis fait de la philosophie avec un
enfant de 6 ans vous serez bluffés fait
de la philosophie ce avec un adolescent
prêt à aller à la fac
vous serez déçu ça montre bien que très
tôt on a de l'ambition on a une
ouverture d'esprit qui nous permet
d'avoir beaucoup d'inspiration
enfin je voudrais terminer par une
dernière remarque on a souvent tendance
à voir la vie comme quelque chose de
planifier petit 1 ont gravi les échelons
scolaire petit deux on obtient un emploi
petit roi on devient proprio à 33 ans on
a deux enfants et on est mariés
petit 4 ans s'installe au fin fond de la
creuse et on a une vie pose hey on est
en 2018
l'ère des nouvelles technologies l'ère
du changement perpétuel est une chose
qui caractérise nos enfants c'est qu'ils
sont justement limitless
ils sont sans limites nous en tant
qu'adulte on a tendance à voir ça comme
de la démesure on n'y croit pas on en
rigole on a peur si vous voulez vraiment
réaliser vos ambitions
apprenez à retrouver votre âme d'enfant
et à ne jamais avoir peur je pense que
les enfants sont très très très très
inspiré et donc très très très très
inspirant nous avons énormément de
choses à leur transmettre
mais eux également retour peuvent nous
apporter énormément et donc comme je
vous le disais pour être ambitieux il ne
faut dont il faut donc retrouver ses
yeux d'enfant son âme d'enfant ne pas
avoir peur et de pas avoir peur du
changement surtout car comme le
professer william shakespeare que
insouciant ville longtemps
merci d'avoir écouté un jeune prof
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]